as we were recording secluded in the
mountains what I didn't know was that
quarantine was going to happen I started
secluding myself in January the ban I
didn't know this is going to continue
for a year but I we've kind of been in
quarantine for a little bit well there
once were roars now they're just that
goes the handshakes and the hugs of your
are now too dangerous but I don't
believe in fear I don't believe in panic
I don't believe in all of its complexity
this damn virus has any idea what it's
up against I thought about where I was
one year before and playing shows and I
thought about those moments I think the
video does a really good job of
capturing just the joy and I was out in
the crowd I would shake hands hugging
were all next to each other there was
that inclusiveness that fellowship and I
think that that does a really good job
of showing where we were and that's
really when I wrote this I'm not a
hundred percent sure I didn't write this
for me as much as is anybody else there
was no agenda
[Music]
the battle rages tomorrow
the thing that got shook me the most
about Vegas was that was my safe place I
never in a million years as messed up as
the world is I never in a million years
thought that that would be a danger area
that could be a dangerous place so no
matter what when people come back they
have to feel that it's okay to be there
that they can experience it the way they
want experience it they should be able
to go up and throw their arms around the
person next to them they should not be
scared about being three feet away and
not six I think that is critical you
Buddha's get their rocks off on top
phone and radio to love it daddy's final
time rocking the skies still reviled in
the Burbank Jeff Tweedy it's one bad
move [ __ ] to me
understood
based on misunderstood most greatest
time of an artist career in my opinion
is when they have a brand new album of
brand new product and they're the only
ones that get to react with it and
listen to them and carry it around and
I've got to do that longer than I
thought but because of Pacifica
situation so I've been living with it
everyday
just me and going through the 28 or 30
song then just kind of going through
those things and experiencing those
things because once we put that out it's
not mine anymore than this the world but
for right now is mine
[Music]